[Musique]
derniers coups de balai et de
débroussailleuses dans la cour du
collège henri matisse à la ravine des
cabris à quelques jours de la rentrée
scolaire les agents techniques du
département termine les derniers travaux
d'entretien nettoyage
tu peux du jardin taillé les replanter
entretien du gazon de désherbage et puis
voilà quelques fleurs à améliorer comme
le jardin dans les couloirs les salles
de classe et les cuisines les agents
sont à pied d'oeuvre suis henriette les
chenilles je suis responsable de la
restauration au sein de ce collège
depuis 1994 je travaille avec une bonne
équipe
madame gaza noël à 3pts de responsables
satellite
madame gibralta julienne agents
polyvalents et responsable de la bouche
alors notre mission au sein de ce
collège et de prépa d'accueillir
les élèves du collège et de leur donner
un
repas équilibrés à la rentrée les élèves
prendront possession de ces classes
récemment aménagé les faux plafonds été
refait et les salles dispose désormais
de brasseurs d'air
des travaux financés par la collectivité
donc des langues et des élèves des
objectifs d utiliser rentreront ils ne
seront plus confrontés à cette chaleur
dans un premier temps mais aussi nos
collègues enseignants il sera un peu
plus d'un quart en de plus agréable pour
travailler mais ils auront aussi bien le
confort thermique le confort sonore
parce qu'avec les brasseurs avec les
faux plafonds
quand on quand on parle maintenant ça ne
résonne plus comme cela c'est comme
c'était il y à un mois et demi deux mois
de ça depuis plusieurs jours les agents
du département prépare l'établissement
pour que dès lundi
la rentrée des 5 199 élèves se fasse
dans les meilleures conditions
[Musique]